In this final chapter, we’re
going to look into optimizing
digital systems to make
them smaller, faster,
higher performance, more
energy efficient, and so on.
It would be
wonderful if we could
achieve all these goals at the
same time and for some circuits
we can.
But, in general,
optimizing in one dimension
usually means doing
less well in another.
In other words, there are
design tradeoffs to be made.
Making tradeoffs
correctly requires
that we have a clear
understanding of our design
goals for the system.
Consider two different
design teams:
one is charged with
building a high-end graphics
card for gaming, the other
with building the Apple watch.
The team building
the graphics card
is mostly concerned
with performance
and, within limits, is willing
to trade-off cost and power
consumption to achieve
their performance goals.
Graphics cards have a set size,
so there’s a high priority
in making the system small
enough to meet the required
size, but there’s little to
be gained in making it smaller
than that.
The team building the watch
has very different goals.
Size and power consumption
are critical since it has fit
on a wrist and run all day
without leaving scorch marks
on the wearer’s wrist!
Suppose both teams are
thinking about pipelining
part of their logic for
increased performance.
Pipelining registers are
an obvious additional cost.
The overlapped execution
and higher t_CLK
made possible by
pipelining would
increase the power
consumption and the need
to dissipate that power somehow.
You can imagine
the two teams might
come to very
different conclusions
about the correct
course of action!
This chapter takes a look at
some of the possible tradeoffs.
But as designers you’ll have to
pick and choose which tradeoffs
are right for your design.
This is the sort
of design challenge
on which good engineers thrive!
Nothing is more satisfying
than delivering more
than anyone thought possible
within the specified
constraints.
Our first optimization
topic is power dissipation,
where the usual goal is to
either meet a certain power
budget, or to minimize power
consumption while meeting
all the other design targets.
In CMOS circuits, there
are several sources
of power dissipation, some
under our control, some not.
Static power
dissipation is power
that is consumed even
when the circuit is idle,
i.e., no nodes are
changing value.
Using our simple switch model
for the operation of MOSFETs,
we’d expect CMOS circuits
to have zero static power
dissipation.
And in the early
days of CMOS, we
came pretty close to
meeting that ideal.
But as the physical dimensions
of the MOSFET have shrunk
and the operating voltages
have been lowered,
there are two sources of static
power dissipation in MOSFETs
that have begun to loom large.
We’ll discuss the effects
as they appear in n-channel
MOSFETs, but keep in mind
that they appear in p-channel
MOSFETs too.
The first effect depends on the
thickness of the MOSFET’s gate
oxide, shown as the thin yellow
layer in the MOSFET diagram
on the left.
In each new generation of
integrated circuit technology,
the thickness of this
layer has shrunk,
as part of the general reduction
in all the physical dimensions.
The thinner
insulating layer means
stronger electrical fields
that cause a deeper inversion
layer that leads to NFETs that
carry more current, producing
faster gate speeds.
Unfortunately the layers
are now thin enough
that electrons can tunnel
through the insulator,
creating a small flow of current
from the gate to the substrate.
With billions of NFETs
in a single circuit,
even tiny currents can add up
to non-negligible power drain.
The second effect is
caused by current flowing
between the drain and
source of a NFET that
is, in theory, not conducting
because V_GS is less
than the threshold voltage.
Appropriately this effect is
called sub-threshold conduction
and is exponentially
related to V_GS -
V_TH (a negative value
when the NFET is off).
So as V_TH has been reduced
in each new generation
of technology, V_GS -
V_TH is less negative
and the sub-threshold
conduction has increased.
One fix has been to change
the geometry of the NFET
so the conducting channel is a
tall, narrow fin with the gate
terminal wrapped around 3
sides, sometimes referred
to as a tri-gate configuration.
This has reduced the
sub-threshold conduction
by an order-of-magnitude
or more,
solving this particular
problem for now.
Neither of these effects is
under the control of the system
designer, except of course, if
they’re free to choose an older
manufacturing process!
We mention them here so
that you’re aware that newer
technologies often bring
additional costs that then
become part of the
trade-off process.
A designer does have some
control over the dynamic power
dissipation of the circuit,
the amount of power
spent causing nodes
to change value
during a sequence
of computations.
Each time a node changes
from 0-to-1 or 1-to-0,
currents flow through the MOSFET
pullup and pulldown networks,
charging and discharging the
output node’s capacitance
and thus changing its voltage.
Consider the operation
of an inverter.
As the voltage of
the input changes,
the pullup and pulldown
networks turn on and off,
connecting the inverter’s
output node to VDD or ground.
This charges or discharges
the capacitance of the output
node changing its voltage.
We can compute the
energy dissipated
by integrating the
instantaneous power associated
with the current flow into
and out of the capacitor
times the voltage across the
capacitor over the time taken
by the output transition.
The instantaneous
power dissipated
across the resistance
of the MOSFET channel
is simply I_DS times V_DS.
Here’s the power calculation
using the energy integral
for the 1-to-0 transition
of the output node,
where we’re measuring I_DS using
the equation for the current
flowing out of the output
node’s capacitor: I = C dV/dt.
Assuming that the input signal
is a clock signal of period
t_CLK and that each transition
is taking half a clock cycle,
we can work through the math to
determine that power dissipated
through the pulldown
network is 0.5 f C VDD^2,
where the frequency
f tells us the number
of such transitions per second,
C is the nodal capacitance, and
VDD (the power supply voltage)
is the starting voltage
of the nodal capacitor.
There’s a similar integral
for the current dissipated
by the pullup network when
charging the capacitor and it
yields the same result.
So one complete cycle of
charging then discharging
dissipates f C V-squared watts.
Note the all this power has
come from the power supply.
The first half is dissipated
when the output node is charged
and the other half stored
as energy in the capacitor.
Then the capacitor’s energy is
dissipated as it discharges.
These results are summarized
in the lower left.
We’ve added the calculation
for the power dissipation
of an entire circuit assuming
N of the circuit’s nodes change
each clock cycle.
How much power could be consumed
by a modern integrated circuit?
Here’s a quick
back-of-the-envelope estimate
for a current
generation CPU chip.
It’s operating at, say, 1
GHz and will have 100 million
internal nodes that could
change each clock cycle.
Each nodal capacitance
is around 1 femto Farad
and the power
supply is about 1V.
With these numbers, the
estimated power consumption
is 100 watts.
We all know how hot a
100W light bulb gets!
You can see it would be hard to
keep the CPU from overheating.
This is way too much
power to be dissipated
in many applications,
and modern CPUs
intended, say, for
laptops only dissipate
a fraction of this energy.
So the CPU designers must have
some tricks up their sleeve,
some of which we’ll
see in a minute.
But first notice how important
it’s been to be able to reduce
the power supply voltage in
modern integrated circuits.
If we’re able to reduce the
power supply voltage from 3.3V
to 1V, that alone accounts
for more than a factor of 10
in power dissipation.
So the newer circuit can be
say, 5 times larger and 2 times
faster with the
same power budget!
Newer technologies
trends are shown here.
The net effect is that
newer chips would naturally
dissipate more power if we
could afford to have them do so.
We have to be very clever in how
we use more and faster MOSFETs
in order not to run
up against the power
dissipation constraints we face.
To see what we can do to
reduce power consumption,
consider the following diagram
of an arithmetic and logic unit
(ALU) like the one you’ll design
in the final lab in this part
of the course.
There are four independent
component modules,
performing the separate
arithmetic, boolean, shifting
and comparison operations
typically found in an ALU.
Some of the ALU
control signals are
used to select the desired
result in a particular clock
cycle, basically ignoring
the answers produced
by the other modules.
Of course, just because the
other answers aren’t selected
doesn’t mean we didn’t dissipate
energy in computing them.
This suggests an opportunity
for saving power!
Suppose we could somehow “turn
off” modules whose outputs we
didn’t need?
One way to prevent them from
dissipating power is to prevent
the module’s inputs
from changing,
thus ensuring that no
internal nodes would change
and hence reducing the dynamic
power dissipation of the “off”
module to zero.
One idea is to put latches
on the inputs to each module,
only opening a module’s input
latch if an answer was required
from that module in
the current cycle.
If a module’s latch
stayed closed,
its internal nodes
would remain unchanged,
eliminating the module’s
dynamic power dissipation.
This could save a
substantial amount of power.
For example, the
shifter circuitry has
many internal nodes and so
has a large dynamic power
dissipation.
But there are comparatively
few shift operations in most
programs, so with
our proposed fix,
most of the time those energy
costs wouldn’t be incurred.
A more draconian approach
to power conservation
is to literally turn off
unused portions of the circuit
by switching off
their power supply.
This is more
complicated to achieve,
so this technique
is usually reserved
for special power-saving
modes of operation,
where we can afford the time
it takes to reliably power
the circuity back up.
Another idea is to slow the
clock (reducing the frequency
of nodal transitions) when
there’s nothing for the circuit
to do.
This is particularly
effective for devices
that interact with
the real world,
where the time scales for
significant external events
are measured in milliseconds.
The device can run slowly
until an external event needs
attention, then
speed up the clock
while it deals with the event.
All of these
techniques and more are
used in modern mobile devices
to conserve battery power
without limiting the ability to
deliver bursts of performance.
There is much more
innovation waiting
to be done in this area,
something you may be
asked to tackle as designers!
One last question is
whether computation
has to consume energy?
There have been some interesting
theoretical speculations about
this question — see section
6.5 of the course notes to read
more.